Hallo.
Hallo Guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Kapagan. Ich bin hier zuständig als Assistenz in Tätich.
Mit Ihnen würde ich gerne das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor wir Ihre aktuellen Bescheiden sprechen, möchte ich ein paar Allgemeine fragen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Barbara somer.
Barbara somer.
Brava somer. Können Sie bitte Ihre Nachrone buchen!
Ja.
S N O M M E R.
Somer.
Brava somer!
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 8 50 Jahre alt.
Ich bin am 12. Februar 1963 geboren.
Ich bin 1,72 m groß.
Ich wiege 65 kg.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe seit ungefähr 2-3 Monaten Schmerzen im Bauchbereich.
Meistens immer so rechte Seite. Mal tut es aber auch links weh.
Rechte Seite.
Ob wir Bauchschmerzen haben Sie?
Ja, Oberbauch ist so rechte Seite.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Ja, das sind so stechende Schmerzen.
Stechende Schmerzen.
Stechende Schmerzen haben Sie.
Ihre Schmerzen sind in rechte Oberbauch.
Wir sind Ihre Schmerzen aufgetreten.
Ich kann mich gar nicht einmal daran erinnern.
Die waren mal so ein bisschen da in der letzten Zeit.
Haben Sie zugenommen?
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wann das das erste Mal aufgetreten ist.
Aber ich weiß, dass es in den letzten Wochen überwiegend da ist.
Mal weg, mal da, aber in der Mehrheit häufiger da.
Okay, verstehe ich.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskolopon 1 bis 10?
Wenn 1 leichter und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen meint?
Ich würde sagen, dass es so 4 bis 5.
4 bis 5, okay.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen abhängig von Essen oder Bewegung?
Bewegungsabhängig sind die Schmerzen nicht.
Nur wenn ich etwas zu viel gegessen habe, dann tut es mehr weh.
Nach dem Essen, vielleicht stärken Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, wenn ich sehr viel esse, nicht immer.
Wenn ich nur eine Kleinigkeit esse, tut nichts weh.
Aber wenn ich sehr viel esse, dann merke ich, das sticht dann schon mehr.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen mit Atmen verschlimmend oder verbessen?
Ob die Schmerzen atmenabhängig sind.
Nein, die sind nicht atmenabhängig.
Haben Ihre Beschwerden sich im Laufen der Zeit verschlechtert?
Ja, die sind stärker geworden.
Ganz am Anfang waren die nur leicht, aber in den letzten Wochen hat das eine Intensität zugenommen.
Das tut noch mehr weh.
Ich habe eine Schmerz mit Strahlen ausgelassen.
Nein, das nicht.
Hatten Sie früher eine Beschwerde?
Nein, diese Schmerzen kenne ich von früher nicht.
Haben Sie wegen dieser Schmerzen eine Medikamente angenommen?
Wie meint ihr das? Meint ihr Schmerzmittel?
Ja, Schmerzmittel.
Schmerzmittel habe ich nicht eingenommen.
Waren Sie früher wegen dieser Schmerzen beim anderen Arzt?
Nein, einen Arzt habe ich auch nicht aufgesucht bisher.
Ertragen Sie momentan Ihre Schmerzen?
Ja, die sind da. Mal sind sie da, mal sind sie nicht da, aber ich habe mich dran gewöhnt.
Frau Zoma, gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für Ihre Schmerz?
Nein, ich weiß nicht. Die kommen und gehen.
Ich weiß nur, wenn ich sehr viel gegessen habe, dass die Schmerzen mehr werden.
Die Schmerzen sind schubweise.
Nein, wie meint ihr das? Was heißt schubweise?
Die kommen und gehen.
Sie meinen aber keine Kohle, oder?
Ja, die Kohle ist gut.
Nein, das sind keine Kohle.
Wenn die Schmerzen kommen, bleiben sie gleich.
Das kann manchmal stunden sein, das kann manchmal ein Tag sein.
Dann geht es aber wieder weg.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Schmerzen oder Besonderer oder Fettigen habe.
Nein, nur wenn ich viel esse.
Nur wenn ich viel esse.
Das hat nichts damit zu tun, ob ich Fettiges esse oder ob ich Kohlenhydrate esse.
Nein, nur wenn ich sehr viel esse, wenn die Menge zu viel ist.
Okay, ein paar Stunden.
Frau Zoma, leiden Sie unter Fieber?
Nein, Fieber habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß oder Schütterfrost?
Nein, kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern.
Haben Sie schon erbrochen?
Nein, erbrochen habe ich auch nicht.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, kann ich nicht daran.
Wie ist Ihr appatiert, besonders in letzter Zeit?
Der ist vielleicht ein bisschen weniger geworden, aber nicht sehr viel.
Haben Sie nester Zeit, ungewollt, ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, weder noch.
Ich habe schon immer 65 kg gewohnt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein, Atemnot habe ich nicht nur.
Wie gesagt, wenn ich sehr viel gegessen habe und die Schmerzen sind da,
dann fällt mir das Atemnot ein bisschen schwer.
Trinken Sie Genugwasser?
Ja, ich trinke schon so 2-3 Liter am Tag.
Leiden Sie unter Verstopfung oder Duschfall?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Haben Sie immer einen geregelten Stuhlgang?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, beim Wasserlassen habe ich auch keine Probleme.
Leiden Sie unter Herzklopfen oder Herzrasen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie in Ihrem Stuhlgang Blut gesehen?
Nein, Blutbeimengung habe ich nicht gesehen.
Leiden Sie unter chronische Erkrankungen,
z.B. Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck oder Schilddröse unter Funktion?
Okay.
Blutdruckprobleme habe ich nicht und Diabetes auch nicht.
Mit der Schilddröse gab es auch keine Probleme.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Nein, ich nehme eigentlich keine Medikamente ein.
Bisher habe ich keine eingenommen.
Wurden Sie operiert?
Mir sind die Mandeln entfernt worden
und der Blinddarm ist mal entfernt worden.
Okay.
Haben Sie allergiegegnetwas?
Oder Unfallträglichkeit?
Ja, ich habe eine Grasallergie.
Im Frühjahr, wenn die Gräser wachsen,
dann habe ich dagegen eine Allergie, aber sonst nicht.
Wie sieht Ihre Allergie aus?
Da kriege ich schon große Probleme.
Luftnot, Niesreiz und die Nase läuft
und meine Augen werden rot.
Das ist schon so typische Gräserallergie.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie die Allergie,
eine Medikamente ein?
Also, ja, nein, meistens hat es nicht geholfen.
Ich lasse immer so eine Däsensibilisierung machen.
Desensibilisierung.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich habe mal geraucht, momentan rauche ich nicht mehr.
Ja.
Haben Sie früher geraucht?
Ja, so vor 10 Jahren habe ich aufgehört.
Wie viel Jahr haben Sie geraucht?
Das war ein Drogen für 10 Jahre.
Wie viel Schatzel haben Sie geraucht?
Also, nicht viel.
Ich habe eine Packung so 3-4 Tage lang geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ne, Alkohol habe ich nie getrunken, also selten, ganz selten.
Okay, diese Frage ist nicht persönlich,
sondern Medizinisch.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, nein, um Gottes Willen.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Corona?
Ja, ich habe auch die dritte Impfung gehabt.
Haben Sie alle gründlichen Impfungen erhalten?
Ja, sie meinen Kindliche Impfungen.
Ja, die habe ich damals erhalten.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Ne, wegen der Corona kann man ja gar nicht.
Ich fahre auch nicht im Ausland.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Na ja, meine Mutter, die geht gut.
Die hat mit Blutdruck ein bisschen Probleme,
aber sonst geht es sehr gut.
Die ist so über 80 und hat momentan keine Probleme.
Ihr Vater?
Ja, mein Vater ist auch am Leben.
Der hat einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Der ist ein bisschen pflegebedürftig.
Meine Mutter kümmert sich um Sie.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Der ist zwei Jahre älter als ich.
Dem geht es so weit gut.
Der hat ein bisschen lieber Probleme.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Ich habe eine Tochter, die ist aber schon längst erwachsen, außer Haus.
Ist sie auch gesund?
Sie ist gesund.
Frau Sommer, gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen?
Leber Erkrankungen oder Krebs?
Krebserkrankungen sind nicht bekannt, aber wie ich gesagt habe,
bei meinem Bruder haben die etwas mit der Leber festgestellt.
Ich möchte für Sie kurz zusammenfassen.
Sie haben seit 23 Monaten,
rechts seit ob er bauch,
verschlimmert, schimmert, bauch schimmert,
nachdem Essen,
sagen Sie doch rechts seit ob er bauch schimmert.
Rechts seit ob er bauch schimmert.
Nachdem Essen, sind Ihre Schmerzen verschlimmert.
Sie geben fünf Intensitätpunkte für Ihre Schmerzen.
Früher hatten Sie nicht ähnliche Beschwerden.
In letzter Zeit haben Sie, haben ihr Appatit, hat ihr Appatit vermindert.
Man sagte Appetit hat nachgelassen.
Nachgelassen.
Sie haben keine Probleme, Stullgang und Wasserlastung.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, meinen Sie, ich habe auch etwas mit der Leber, wie mein Bruder.
Zuerst körperliche Untersuchung.
Zuerst möchte ich körperliche Untersuchung.
Und dann möchte ich von Ihnen Blutz abnehmen und Ultraschall durchführen.
Nach und unter der Leber ergeben Sie, kann ich für Sie bechtimt die Diagnose sagen.
Aber ich habe noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Haut Verfarbung bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Von meiner Seite habe ich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Nach der Untersuchung bespreche ich mit meinem Chef über Ihre Symptome.
Alles klar.
Gehen Sie unter Yukreis?
Nein, Yukreis habe ich momentan nicht.
Haben Sie Sotbrennen?
Nein, Sotbrennen habe ich auch nicht.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall gehabt?
Unfall, nein, kein Unfall.
Haben Sie Völle gefühlt?
Nein, so richtig nicht.
Bleiben Sie unter Blähungen?
Nein, Blähungen habe ich auch nicht.
Müssen Sie aufstürzen?
Nein, aufstürzen habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Nein, weder noch.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie unruhig, nervös, müdigkeit,
konzentrationär und Leistung verletzt haben?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Wie erdehren Sie sich, zum Beispiel vegetarisch oder Fleisch essen?
Nein, ich versuche ausgewogen, mich zu ernähren.
Haben Sie das in der Zeit genommen oder abgenommen?
Nein, mein Gewicht ist ganz zeitgleich geblieben.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt, haben Sie kurze Zeit?
Ja, ich habe kurz Zeit.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Frau Barbra Zoma ist 58 Jahre alt und 1,72 Meter groß.
Frau Barbra Zoma ist in unserem Krankenhaus.
Sie sind zugegeben, progressiv, sagt man nicht im Deutschen.
Sie sind langsam begonnen und mit der Zeit stärker geworden.
Sie sind zugegeben, dass Sie sich nicht verschlimmert haben.
Sie trinken gelegentlich Alkohol.
Vor zehn Jahren hat sie Rauchen gestoppt.
Vor zehn Jahren hat sie mit dem Rauchen aufgehört.
Stoppen kann aber wieder weitergehen.
Wenn man sagt aufhören, heißt es nie wieder geraucht.
In Familienanamnese gibt es keine Krebs.
Sein Vater hat einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Er hat einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Er hat eine Leberkrankheit.
Er hat eine Leberprobleme.
Er hat eine Raumforderung.